what was the memorial service like for
your iphone 6 brutal i still miss it and
you know what i've not even wanted to
post this
i feel like my new phone is too heavy
and i know that makes me like the oldest
dinosaur in the world but the problem is
it's right it's right here it's ready
i'm gonna i'm gonna talk some [ __ ] right
now because as i hold it you use the
pinky to like brace it and it feels too
heavy it's too heavy am i the only guy i
got a line here like it's too heavy like
i i need something well so you're saying
pardon me for sentence but you're saying
captain america can't lift an iphone all
right now now you're getting aggressive
now you're trying to get clickbait now
you're trying to make waves i'm just
saying do i miss the home button yeah i
do i missed the home button the home
button was [ __ ] awesome yeah but then
i had a thousand people like get the sc
i'm like no i don't want i want the
iphone 6. i want something from before
to work until it doesn't work anymore
and i don't want apple to be well i
don't want to
you